thank you and thank thanks for staying
so late so you guys must be the hardcore
people interested in finding bugs in
software engineering and machine
learning so some background about my
motivation to do this over the last 20
years or so I played roles in very
different aspects of software
engineering both as a developer as a
manager as an architect both at the
software level and at the database level
and I've been very frustrated by the
lack of structure in the underlying
processes of software engineering and
the way I think about it today is that
we are in an industry that's an advanced
stage of craftsmanship with power tools
and we are about to make a transition to
industrial production of software but we
don't have the the the the means we
don't have the measurements we don't
have the instrumentation needed to do
these things in an automated fashion and
so we end up doing them manually
so that's you'll see some of that later
but my motivation is to take the take
the emotion and the cherry-picking and
the craziness out of reasoning about
software and actually making it
reasoning about software so the rest
you'll see as we go along so about me I
have a bachelor's and EE from many years
ago before the meteors came and the
dinosaurs died I went to ended a
master's in applied math and then I was
in a PhD pure math program and it got
too crazy so I did everything but thesis
and I went back to software development
so as I've mentioned I've done all of
these things you you're free to look
look up learn data science learn HTTP
learn bs dot-coms a bunch of ipython
notebooks to teach yourself data science
if you're a software developer and want
to go in and learn that it comes with
you just clone the gate repository and
you'll get everything including the
datasets and everything so I encourage
you to do that and so I was on a recent
project with a company called perforce
and some of the older people may have
used perforce some of the newer people
may have been forced to use perforce
but I learned a lot about version
control systems and there are some very
positive things about perforce that are
often missed and one of them is that it
saves all the history of your project
which means that you can do data mining
on it and so one of the things that came
out of doing that project was that I did
this would have this startup and started
doing data mining and software
repositories not just perforce so the
current what we'll do is we look at the
current state of software development
and see what is the meaning of risk in
software development and how do we
quantify it because there's always risk
of of things breaking of not delivering
software of many different things and
and we often argue about it intensely
but we don't have a base to reason from
a data driven base to reason from
increasingly with applying analytics to
some parts of it we're getting better
but what I'll show you here is that
there are major aspects that are missing
and some things we're doing just wrong
and hopefully we can do this better so
the idea is how do we make this more
industrial like and to do that we need
to have some instrumentation and sensors
and to create feedback loops so that
it's not an open-loop control system
most of the times you run it and then it
breaks and then you say oh man that
broke and then we start over again and
so we can try to surface errors early
that's what feedback loops do they're
very early measurements of errors so
that corrective feedback can be applied
and are there signals in the software
engineering process to do that so notice
I'm not saying that I'm going to get
into your code so that's the first thing
to notice is that I'm not analyzing code
I'm not understanding the language I'm
looking at the various artifacts that
come out of the software engineering
process which is commits issues and in
the future logs and in the even after
that the story text so I want to look at
all the metadata of the software
engineering process and to see if we can
see signals and we can build correlative
and predictive models based on this
which makes it then language independent
and makes it independent of the
particular tools and techniques you
might be using because all of this is
also information about your software
engine process and the idea is can we
use it to do predict things
and so how do we do this and the why
can't we have nice things is because we
did this software always seems easy when
you start and then when you're close to
delivery it seems impossibly hard and
this has not gone away and and so until
we fix this or until we have an idea of
how do we predict how our project is
doing well ahead of time and identify
these areas in a reasonable way in a way
that we can quantify and reason about
then we are doomed and so the idea that
I mentioned earlier is that we are at a
cost from craftsmanship with power tools
to industrial production and yet our
tools are still sort of Stone Age tools
with polish and we we have a sort of way
of speaking about these things
internalizing some of the lessons and
passing them on which is which is not
scalable and that's why we we have a
theory that if we have enough wizards
then we won't have any problems but
wizards don't scale and so that's a
zero-sum game of trying to hire away
wizards from other people and what we
really need to do is to take the
knowledge about the process that we've
learned and and make it available to
machines which can scale easily and then
the humans can do the creative part so
that's the that's the big picture is how
much of this knowledge can be used by
machines to scale up our processes
better and so if you've seen the Martian
then the last line will make some sense
to you but basically we are trying to
apply science to the software
engineering process and in other
industries where they have very complex
processes that go on very very dangerous
things I mean this guy standing next to
this boiler if everything was not
controlled it would explode and kill him
but we have confidence in our systems
because over the years we've we've taken
our knowledge and we'd externalized it
we've started to other people and then
we have put it in these sensors and
instruments that have encoded all this
collective knowledge over the years so
that a little reading on a valve can
tell us you know we need to release
pressure from somewhere else we don't
have these sensors in software
engineering we don't know where to
release the valve to release the
pressure that's going to cause this
project to blow up two months down the
line and so that's what we want to be
able to do if we can do it
and therefore we since we don't have
that we can't have this big vision of
where what is my software in my
enterprise doing in Fortune 500
companies often they have they have
software they have hundreds of
applications but they don't know who's
using what and which application is
obsolete and can I shut this down and
not use it anymore without somebody in
some remote Department saying hey I
can't do my job anymore so we need we
need a way to effectively build what is
the SA P of software applications and
assets so that we can manage them better
but we have way far from that what we
need is feedback loops and a typical
industrial system you have these things
that identify errors and then apply
corrective loops if we don't have those
and what we have instead is a bunch of
acronyms and and a manager that's
worried about what is this new acronym
that's come along and and we'll it may
help me ship faster better cheaper but
developers want to have this latest
acronym on their resume so that's what
we use and then it blows up and then you
know we curse so this is in my sort of I
drew this by the way this is my picture
of software development as it is today
but let's take a look at it from an
industrial production point of view
these are the various stages we go
through in software development and we
throw away most of the things that have
the signal that's the thing that I've
identified as data exhaust and it's data
that it comes as a side-effect of our
software engineering but and it contains
a lot of signals we can correlate some
of these signals for instance each run
logs might tell you what files are
contain a particular bug and we might
want to save them and look at some
correlations between changes we made and
how things crashed in the field or even
when you're running tests but we don't
and so we lose a lot of this information
but that's the stuff that I'm pulling
out and I've started with issues and
commits and issues for some specific
projects and I've done this over three
or four proprietary projects for
perforce was my first customer and then
over a bunch of Apache projects
what I found is that there is a wide
variation in the discipline on how we do
software development which makes it
either easy or hard to build these
correlative models and I'll talk about
that in a second but the stuff that you
see on the right the feature eyes model
predict that's what we do at numeric and
then we want to take these signals and
put them back so you can see that this
is the beginnings of a feedback loop and
so two things that we've done one of
which I'll show you is is to actually
extract features from commits that from
your own history make them buggy and so
the next commit that comes along I
should be able to tell you hey does this
look like a buggy commit or does this
look like a clean commit and I should be
able to give you a warning with the
understanding that it's not always
hundred percent correct but I should be
able to warn you of the commits that
come along and then you go and you
hopefully get it reviewed or you go take
a second look at it and so that's how we
started and we built basically a random
forest model over a lot of the
attributes that will be extracted from
commits collisions so that's where the
scikit-learn and random forests came
along and what we found was there was a
risk score or a number that with what
was being applied to each of the files
in the system and so I tried to make
sense of this is why our certain outcome
it's considered buggy and why are
certain other commits being flagged as
safe and is it helped to do with the
files that are in this how does it have
to do with the developer does it have to
do with the time it is checked in so all
of these things matter but the question
I was not able to answer is is it
because of the file and that was really
problematic because I wanted to know if
there are certain files that are buggier
than other files and what I wanted to do
was to go backwards from files to bugs
in other words tell me all the bugs that
have been logged that include this file
and what I found was you can't do that
with our systems today so hold that
thought for a second and we'll go it so
so the questions we want to ask is can
we build a predictive model and can be
used to get early warnings and can be
use it to do what if analysis like what
if I added more people what if I
I wanted to get more done what if I
release today etc and Khalid can I can
some recommended best practices come out
of this get it help me improve this
stuff and can it show me stuff that I
don't know so surprising results is
always a useful thing when you're
building a predictive model because if
it predicts stuff you already know then
it's the complete waste of time so the
answer to it short answer to all of that
is yes and we will see how we can do all
this so again a little cartoon a version
of software development and what we have
on the left is what typically happens
and you shouldn't get too much
importance to the shapes of these things
except that you always want to keep
adding features because to stay
competitive your software has to evolve
and there are market pressures to keep
adding features but underlying this
complexity grows and you have to keep
your apically dealing with increasing
risk except you don't know what that
risk is and you can't put your finger on
it and so management of complicated
software projects is done by gut feel by
people who've done this before people
who have internalized these lessons but
can't tell you why they think things are
going better or worse and what my goal
is to extract these in from this
information and externalize it so that
you can make decisions and you can see
on the right side you have the risk line
has become solid instead of the dotted
line which suggests something going on
that you can't put your finger on and
the green line is some sort of safe
thing that we have each person has a
different level gut feeling of what is
safe and what is not and what we really
want to do is to externalize this risk
and to damp it because we now can
measure it under lie under whatever it
is that you're your local measure of
safety is and so here are questions that
we can barely answer today what are my
top 10 buggiest files I couldn't answer
that question so why would you want to
know that because maybe you want to
focus your testing on that first before
you build tests for all the other stuff
and there's some very interesting thing
that comes out of this that we're really
doing testing wrong so what and now I
want to intersect this what are my top
10 files that are buggiest and changed
the most because if I tell you that
these five files have historically the
most buds and oh by the way most people
are working on it so your hair should
rise at the back of your neck thinking
this is where most future bugs I'm gonna
cover so can we correlate changes to
bugs and the real question is what do we
need to do that and the funny thing
today is that we can't share correlate
changes to bugs with the tools that we
have so why is that and this is one
picture about why we can't have good
things so these solid blue lines here
suggest that there are some barriers in
between these data stores and so we have
changes in one area and if you use git
and JIRA them the first to apply to you
and if he was perforce if you're using
their job system which is an ability to
actually put tasks and your permits and
the same data store then you don't need
any of these others and but what you're
seeing here is that in your software
development pipeline you have various
artifacts that are coming out and the
problem we have is that we can't
correlate them in the data formats that
we have today so one of the first things
I started by doing was to get issues and
to get commits and to find which commits
ended up which bug which commits were
bug fixed commits which means that was
the area where the bug was so I look at
bug fix commits and then I look at zero
issues and I try to correlate them and
this is where the difficulty lies
because in many cases people are not
following a disciplined approach of
putting the bug fix the bug ID in the
commit that simple act of putting the
bug ID in the commit bootstrap this
process of industrial modeling of this
process and if we don't do that then the
cause causal connection is lost right
because we don't know what change is
fixing what bug and we want to be able
to do that and if we can't then we
better be doing that and this is the
underlying what I found is an underlying
people familiar with entity relationship
diagram or is it a thing that is dead
now
but but what we have F stands for files
i stands for issues and C stands for
changes and this is the underlying model
almost the canonical core model of
software development
and this is what I discovered when
trying to find the reverse connection
between issues and and files and the
dotted line there is that I can't find
that unless I do something with the data
stores that I have and so as you can see
each of these different things get zero
paper to tracker
they're like the blind man and the
elephant and they're looking at
different attributes of the same bigger
entity and they are not getting the big
picture so if you go back here what my
company in America has done and and we
will be open sourcing various aspects of
this in the future is to extract all of
this stuff into a common data model
people who do bi and data warehouses and
fact Able's is a fact table anybody mean
anything to anyone anybody here
no one fact table okay so what we've
essentially done is create a data
warehouse and built fact tables of for
all your software engineering history
and then the measures are actually the
severity we've created a synthetic
measure of severity which is how much
residual unfixed bugs if that's a way to
think about it remain in this area so
once you do that then you can do
traditional bi and build cubes and you
can you can do all kinds of interesting
stuff there that's when we can have good
things and then dashboards that
everybody loves and if you're not the
dashboard type then you can actually
give you a command prompt where you can
sit down and and do queries on it and so
the water part comes out of this so what
is net severity measure so it's
something that's lingering risk or
various ways to think about it although
it's just a number how is the risk
distributed across files is a way to
think about it at the file level and
then once you can go down to the file
level you can aggregate it up to modules
and and other higher things but it most
importantly is to think of a measure of
aside from risk it's a measure of
technical debt because there's stuff
that needs to be still dealt with and
maybe the answer is not to fix it the
bug but maybe it is to refactor so
whatever it is it's a measure of work
that remains to be done and so that's
kind of the core
software-development like life cycle
dimensional model for people who are
familiar with these terms so current
matrix what we get in the current world
is something called a burn down chart
which tells you how we are fixing bugs
and how many bugs remain to be fixed
before release and so that's got time on
the x-axis and number of bugs on the
y-axis and then you have this commits
versus time it's like how features are
increasing and how much activity there
is which is number of commits versus
time but so in all these cases time is
the independent variable but in reality
time is not the driver of breakage it's
changes letter driver of breakage so
unless you join these two together and
make commits as the independent variable
you're not going to figure out how
brittle your code is because what you
really want to identify is what areas if
it called can be changed with less
breakage and what area of your code can
be really have to watch out for and and
on some level for a small enough project
everybody knows where the skeletons are
buried and everybody knows not to touch
that one file or that area don't touch
that area only XYZ knows and now he's
left the company this is not this is not
a uncommon occurrence and so there are
areas of the code that using stuff like
this you can you can surface them you
can quantify them and you can go to the
powers-that-be and say look the amount
of stuff that we have that needs to be
fixed and so that needs to be in your
next budget or that's what we need to do
for a while so the idea here is that
using this kind of quantification you
can have a reasoning reason based
discussion rather than this gut feeling
discussion that we tend to have and I've
been on all sides of this in in this
I've been the person at the other end
saying give me proof and I've been the
other the other other side saying I'm
cherry-picking some things here and
there and trying to prove your point for
which there are counter examples and so
what I'm trying to do here is to build a
scientific model of how risk is
distributed over your project and so
brittleness is some a word to keep in
mind and so we built this thing called
the numeric quad risk model which which
basically says where the changes are low
and the changes are high and where the
breakage is low in the breakage is high
and this by the way we can see
but from the previous model when you
built this bi model you can do sums and
counts on different dimensions and you
can find out which files have high
changes low risk etc and and so what you
want is that the stuff that's read above
that line is the stuff with high
breakage now I'll explain these these
letters B R stands for brittle
he used stands for unstable d stands for
done and S stands for stable and I'll
explain that in a second with the caveat
that the U is where all all files begin
their life in this unstable mode where
you're writing and changing and writing
and breaking and changing but eventually
they migrate to these other areas and
what you really want is that the stuff
above the line should not be growing as
your project goes along so if you
remember the cartoon ordered true there
was this green line dotted line you can
think of this line as that dotted line
and if stuff starts moving up above this
line then your project is moving into an
riskier phase for whatever reason and if
that's happening towards release then
that's a problem it can happen for a
period of time when you everybody is
working on the new features and then the
testing begins it has to go down it
can't get unstable and that's that's a
very simple way of thinking about it so
one of the things that I put some
numbers in there one of the things which
I'll talk about in a minute I have found
out on many of these is that that a
typical code base three to five percent
of the files have most of the CD severe
bugs and 80% of the files don't have any
severe bugs at all some of them don't
have any bugs at all logged against them
that doesn't mean that there is not a
bug there but I'm looking at purely at
history bugs that have been logged in
the past and and when you do that so
I've put in some numbers here a 3% or
brittle and assume that 10% of your code
base is changing for every iteration and
that's 13 and I saw I just made up some
other numbers to put in the bottom the
idea here is these are percentages so
even if you keep adding files this is a
percentage number so from one week to
the next from one iteration to the next
the numbers above the line growing
higher or are the numbers below the line
growing higher and if above the line the
numbers are doing higher you have a
problem and below the line if your
numbers are going then you're going
better and you're able to damp the risk
and you can go back and drill down and
I'll show you how we've actually
visualize this for a couple of projects
the HBase project is a project that I
started off with and now I'm right now
doing it for the apache spark project
that'll be another couple of days and
and some of this will be open sourced
and I'd like people who are interested
in this too please join me I've been
doing this alone with the team in
Ukraine and I want to open-source this
stuff so that people can take some of
the stuff and start improving the
software engineering process but also
contribute your results back so it can
be a learning experience for the
industry and it's very early but I think
there's a lot that can be done here and
it tremendous amount of value that can
be created for everybody so this thing
that you see on the screen can even be
on it can even be on your phone and your
project manager can be just looking at
these numbers every iteration remotely
every day if they want if that's when
you update the stuff and this is the
kind of conversation that we have not
been able to have between engineers
their managers and all the way up to
change forever and so going back to this
what I'm saying here is that this
diagram is sort of a quantitative
version of this thing where if you can
keep your files below that line growing
then you've damped the risk and this is
a little bit hand wavy but I hope you've
seen the quantification beyond behind
that now this is the thing that I wanted
to show you is and by the way power laws
happen
everywhere in software engineering if
you go look at the research there are
lot of people at universities that do
research on software engineering and
quantitative research and they find not
just bugs with files but lot of other
issues have power loss and so it's not
normally distributed and it's not
uniformly distributed and so the problem
we have in the industry today is that
test coverage assumes that risk is
uniformly distributed across your files
and if you look at this diagram up there
take a look at the area in the left and
there's a tremendous amount of risk
but we don't have coverage of that and
then stuff to the right is where we are
wasting effort and so one of the things
that came out the surprising thing for
me that came out was that maybe if you
start by focusing using these numeric
measures the area where the biggest risk
lies your effective coverage of actual
risk would be better than simply looking
at lines of government files and it
would be more effective the same amount
of resources would be more effective in
actually catching bugs as opposed to
consuming CPU cycles every time the
continuous integration kicks in because
we're not only wasting 80% of the effort
in a very hand wavy fashion but we are
also doing it now continuously every day
so we are more efficiently in an
automated fashion wasting resources so
I'm going to take a minute and and demo
for you a visualization of how this
would actually work in practice and so
I've taken data from an HBase Apache
HBase project and the JIRA issues and
the commits from git pull them in
process them done all this joining and
messy cleanup stuff and built
effectively a cube in a second so this
is now if people if you're familiar with
tableau this is something we've created
in tableau and I'm going to explain a
little bit of what all this stuff is so
first let me remove this part so what
you're getting here is simply the areas
the times of the year where what green
stuff means and what red stuff means is
this we compute something called
brittleness which is the severity the
net severity which is an aggregate of
high high severity bugs it's a measure
of bad things and degree in the
denominator we have change how many
changes we had so there were 100 commits
and the net severity was
Oh point one or we had 20 comets in the
net severity was 20 so you will see red
in the in the in the second one and you
will see green in the first one because
a lot of change didn't cause too much
severity to go up and so this is
actually measuring how the severity
changed from one month to the next okay
so things got worse and then they got
better and this thing this pattern is
something that you see in a healthy
project this is actually healthy where
you're adding features and then you're
logging bugs and then you're fixing bugs
and this is this is a sort of a cycle
that you it's kind of a healthy heart
beat in a project that should be the way
it is what you don't want is you're
about to release and then you have a
bunch of unresolved red things and so
I'm gonna break this down now and with
the kind of data model we have we can do
that
so Apache projects have this thing
called components and every time you log
a bug you actually include what
component it was and and often in JIRA
yes previous slide or previous view yes
okay yes
yes yes yes yes yes no I mean that is
not being associated with this time
frame it's being associated with when
it's reported and then it gets fixed so
there's a certain lag there's a certain
lag in there that isn't is in the nature
of software develop and we can peel
these off but this is the very first
this is kind of the very first attempt
at this so yes there it's more nuanced
than what it appears so let's go back to
what we'll be doing component so what
you can look at now is well I can I can
remove this and remove this so that's a
better and now what you can look at is a
particular component if there's a lot of
activity going on if there's a lot of
whites it means there's not a lot of
activity going on and you can see
there's a lot of activity going on and
doesn't break too much but whoa was that
I hope that was not released because
there was closed and so we can keep
discussing these things so the areas
where you have a lot of dark reds are I
would say areas where some of the risk
is located and this is just one view we
can do some clustering on this because
now we have numeric measures we can do
clustering on the numeric measures we
can do all kinds of things and which I
haven't done yet and and so this is how
for instance it would look sliced by
just the one level above files now if
you want to the next thing we can do is
go to priority so what what you can now
look at is that in any particular thing
what about the critical bugs and how
much of this is associated with that and
how fast are we fixing critical bugs you
want intense rates to be followed by
intense greens and you don't want
intense Reds hanging around for too long
most certainly not and then what you can
also do is and this is the part where
things get a little how much I have 5%
hopefully I'll finish before that so now
we're looking at who's fixing the bugs
and maybe people need help with some
things maybe people are overloaded and
and the one of the things that I want to
really very strongly warned about is to
not use any of these analytic tools as
blunt weapons to fire people right
because some of this stuff shows how
activity is happening and typically if
somebody's having difficulty my
approaches now this is a data-driven
reason to give them mentoring and
support you've already taken all the
effort to hire them and gone through all
that overhead here's data to help them
get better right so that's a person
based based thing a sliced by module and
time and you can take this down all the
way to the file level if you want but
for any one model there are way too many
files on this and that the information
is sparse when looked at for so for a
human being it's more useful to look at
the aggregated areas so that's why I
said when buggy parts of your code base
rather than bugs in your file and so
those are the areas where which I am NOT
correlating it is or does it have tests
how many tests does it have and is there
is the coverage there so this is an
example of what you can do in a very
early phase if you put your data in the
right right fashion and so the takeaway
is I would say are we can't have good
things because some of the things we
just doing them wrong and our software
engineering data is in silos and there
is a canonical data model underneath but
we are not using it so what should we do
and there's gold in your repositories
but we can't mine it right now
so the one thing if I would say to take
away from this and you don't do anything
you forget my name you forget everything
else but just remember this one thing is
to put the issue ID in the bug fixed
omit and preferably put it in a standard
place everywhere and an example of this
and if I have time in the QA I will show
you examples of how the step a cheese
park project does it and they do it very
well and that's probably the best
practice to follow is that they put the
bug fix in the in the commit message in
square brackets the JIRA ID followed in
square brackets by the component that
they are fixing it so they have a lot of
metadata in a strongly typed fashion so
that machines can go and extract this
information when you don't have that you
can't automate this process of pulling
this stuff out so aside from actually
doing this I learnt a lot about the
state of software engineering discipline
in the industry it's getting better and
I think Apache is playing a bigger role
just by following common processes but
include the story ID if you if you have
some kind of an ID for your stories and
code metrics are important but your code
could be perfect and your configuration
could be wrong and your stuff won't
deploy so the whole process end-to-end
is important and maintaining history is
important if you want to get the best
out of this and maintaining structure in
your process so that's the some of it
and if you want to learn data science
there's a learn deers combine of ipython
notebooks you can follow me on Twitter
for some machine learning some comedy
and some other things so anyway that was
my so five minutes question answers or
the early so we have ten minutes of Q&A
and I can get into a little bit of code
to look at if you want but any spirit
yes
yes so what I'm what I'm pulling so
question when you're collecting this
information are you collecting severity
of the bug so yes what I'm doing is
counting this severe the top to severity
levels as bug in my model and I'm
ignoring all the other levels which I
usually feature changes and requests and
nice-to-haves and all of that and I'm
calling them non bugs ok so that's how
I'm doing that and that's the threshold
and then I'm doing some thresholding on
that after I build my model yes
yes yes right so I'm going to repeat
your question is in the process it's
also important to mark things as done so
that it's open versus closed and that's
important because one of the severity
measures is how many open buds do we
have against this and so yes I mean that
is more amore basic than putting the ID
he's marking it as close but I
understand there are a number of these
things and my hope in the future is a
number of these things can be part of
our tools so when you open a commit you
you just you can even click on the issue
and say fix and then it pulls up your
IDE and populates this information
there's really no need for humans to be
doing all this right so that's the
longer term is like once we built this
metadata and once we've done all this we
can use it to link up our tools and
create a much more automated process so
this the number of windows we have
opened and the number of cut and paste
we do between entirely different kinds
of data stores is ridiculous and we are
to be doing all of that through a
uniform interface anyway questions yes
yes
yes I I do I do take into account open
bugs and the net severity is basically
closed versus open so it's open bugs is
is a measure of net severity for you
well we don't we are not able to
associate things with open but we can
associate things that have been reopened
so so that's that's a measure right
because if the bug was fixed and
reopened we are we get a lot of that
some of the more severe bugs are opened
and closed more times but that's that's
right now a gray area what what does get
marked is against what subsystem are we
saying so somebody says it's a UI bug or
somebody says it's a database bug so we
at least know not necessary at the file
level but at the module level that
something happened but it depends on the
person logging the bug yeah yeah I mean
if you want to talk to me afterwards
about how I can apply this to your
process happy please call me or talk to
me here for me yeah yes tablo themselves
have a tableau of public and so one of
the things I what I'm hoping to do is to
make it interactive because that's where
the power is but then you have to put
the whole model somewhere and host it
yes yes that we can do yeah okay thank
you